we don't have any music today okay it's
on vacation so
corridor oh that's beautiful actually
that's copyright that's yeah oh dang it
this whole video is now
freaking with the copies of rights
i want to open here by asking you guys
if i look like the most chill beach dude
of all time
oh i got a surf shirt got some some
crocs on
you're selling us on it but i'm going to
go with the hard no i think fenner looks
more beach right now man oh so hard no
yeah well i mean you've got gel in your
hair that's what i was gonna say i was
getting gel in my hair i got greased
salt and i got
the natural i got salt water because ren
and i were at the beach at the beach
this morning should we introduce who we
are real quick for all of our audio
listeners yeah i'm i'm wren
i'm jordan i'm fenner and i'm dean so
that's who we are yay so the beach am i
right yeah let's talk about the beach
there's water
and there's cool guys like dean
fenner was at the beach you said you
were surfing this morning i was we
almost
like
i must have been like a few blocks away
from you guys wait
wait what yeah
i was just south of you guys you were at
the beach this morning when we were yeah
different beach though but just south of
you guys like okay yeah i couldn't we
were straight up at santa monica like we
were just south of the the pier santa
monica pier and for context we were
getting a shot for this caustics video
that was working on but i thought how
funny because i there's this shot i'm
holding a boom pole with a scuba mask on
why has ren's coming out of the water
how funny it would have been if it was
fenner on a surfboard
with with the boom pole following you in
so you're running
[Laughter]
so i mean yeah i feel like we can't say
that without also giving context onto
this video that we're doing
um
sorry what
oh yeah i guess it's out now hey go
check it out on uh quarterdigital.com or
on youtube if that's where you're at
it's
that'll tell you all you need to know
and hopefully it's done by then
yes no promises as of right now it's not
done this video is a very very unique
one even for me because it's like
it's got all of the same sort of things
i've done in a scale video before but
also none of them
it's a weird weird sort of paradox it's
a hybrid you're kind of going more off
script on this one a little bit yeah so
i've i've been struggling with writing
in general in my life the last like year
half year started with the solar world
video that kind of
broke my life a little bit but uh
yeah my this this caustics video was my
attempt to like okay come up with a new
format that's essentially like that
without the actual script and so we kind
of just like
uh outlined it kind of made all these
different moments
made it like sort of a beat list we even
like wrote them out on flash cards and
like reassemble them to kind of get the
the structure of the video put together
because this video is about something
that is so like
niche so esoteric like not a single
person i've started describing this
video to understood what i meant when i
said it's about caustic so like uh what
even my parents i spent like 10 minutes
describing uh the caustics video to them
last night yeah last night and
it wasn't until i literally showed them
a render of a of a crystal prism and
like the dispersion on the ground that
they're like oh that's what you meant i
was like i literally already defined it
and everything for you guys so it's like
not that that's a bad thing it's just it
reinforces that this is like such a
randomly like
specific thing or something you just get
used to seeing isn't it you just
we see caustics all the time we just
don't think about them exactly unless
you're in the middle yeah unless you're
not
unless you're literally trying to render
caustics the video is kind of you
working on this has kind of broken my
brain because now i'm seeing them
everywhere the other morning i woke up
and threw like the people on my door it
was casting like this rainbow circle on
the wall and i was like i have never
noticed it until you started this video
i uh um to reinforce again the point i'm
making i should probably also define
caustics a little bit more clearly it's
like the patterns of light you get on
the other side of glass or water you
know like the little patterns you see at
the bottom of pools and stuff like that
if you take like a prism or any sort of
like jewelry like the cool like little
patterns of light you get passing
through it if you if you see light
passing through a window and landing on
your wall there's probably some sort of
pattern to it it's probably a square
pattern that's technically a caustic
and
rendering that is one of the hardest
things because of how rendering works
it essentially just takes a very very
very long time to render it and part of
what got me going on this video was
a new octane render kernel a new type of
rendering that they released um they
announced it like last december i think
but it just came out as a cinema 4d
plugin
like in the last month and it does
caustic rendering a thousand times
faster than ever before and so suddenly
i'm it's like the fact that we're able
to do this so quickly now
well just a little bit more so quickly
so like
some of your render times like insane
and because you need crazy samples right
yeah yeah and that's
exactly it's like
caustics no one ever really does
caustics because it just takes too long
to render we're talking like years like
real candlesticks real caustics yeah and
so another chunk of this video is
talking about fake caustics if you're to
literally search how to render caustics
on youtube right now
every single result on the top 50 are
all going to be doing
faked caustics usually with like some
sort of gobo style thing like blocking
the light in an interesting pattern
others will do it with like a photon
mapping type thing it's a biased type of
rendering it's not exactly
specially correct it's not real uh
they're all like kind of faked versions
to accelerate that rendering like speed
so now with the new rendering kernel how
long does it take
to get a noise free
costing so i've i've been doing these
renders for last two weeks now and just
i always have my home computer going and
my work computer going at all times
pretty much and i've kicked out almost
two dozen renders and
on some scenes it actually renders
pretty quickly what i've found is that
you have to have very simple geometry
for the caustics to be hitting so all of
the renders with like the wood that i
had with like the nice bump mapping and
like the normal maps and the roughness
maps it's taking a long time to render
that out to get it to be noiseless
how unbiased rendering works is that it
starts super noisy and as it samples
each pixel longer and longer that pixel
becomes more and more accurate and
what we end up seeing is that the
renders get less and less noisy so
anytime you see a render that's like
noisy they just didn't have enough time
to render it yeah you've been there a
lot and that's where like denoising
comes in you can denoise your renders
but the built-in denoising doesn't work
on the new caustic stuff yet i've not
been able to use that so to in order to
get it to
render noiseless you have to let it go
longer and on that one shot it took 100
hours to render a 200 frame sequence
that's crazy it's like six and a half or
seven seconds and that's with the new
photon that's with the new photon tracer
in fact in the footage uh that i
provided um
i pull out my phone i'm like hey siri
how long is
uh 100 hours 100 000 hours because if
it's a thousand times faster presumably
it'd take a hundred thousand hours oh
interesting
presumably but it's not exactly how it
works uh and that's like 11 years oh my
goodness oh my god
wow
like so we've been working on this video
i i was like okay i have to understand
how
rendering works
at a level to understand how like why is
caustics hard yeah and you spoke with uh
jules the head of oh toy for the video
and he had a very
nice explanation of the photon tracer in
octane
after like an entire day of like reading
like even to the point of reading like
research papers and stuff like oh my god
how do i understand this i understand it
less now
i i feel like i can relate i spent quite
a bit of time researching this stuff and
then i'm like all right i feel like i'm
getting a grasp on it and then someone
will ask me about it i'll be like
uh
uh
uh
transport it goes from the light and
into the
man i guess i don't know anything about
this dang it because i
is photo this is about to get super like
esoteric but like is photon mapping
ray tracing or is it like
yeah
kind so ray tracing is an unbiased
sorry ray tracing is a biased artifact
that you can put into biased renders
path tracing is unbiased right and
i can never remember whether or not the
ray is shooting from the camera bouncing
around a scene and then hitting a light
source or if it starts at the light
source bounces around the scene and hits
the the camera i think that one might be
ray tracing
i could be wrong i think the primary
rays come from the camera first yes and
the secondary come from the lights
but someone's gonna kill me in the
comments with that i'm pretty sure i'm
not a hundred percent i thought ray
tracing is like one ray and path tracing
is like multiple rays with more bounce
well they're all
exactly see like i have literally read
multiple articles on the distinction
between ray tracing and path tracing and
i still am unable to articulate the
difference which just tells you how
smart these people are who design these
uh render engines
because
again jules was explaining like oh well
so you know we tweak uh progressive
photon mapping and all these different
things in these ways so that you can
have caustics a thousand times faster
and he's like it's not quite this it's a
little bit more of that and because yeah
if you just have a the most base level
understanding of rendering you're like
it's easy you know you shoot a ray out
and it bounces around
but
yeah it's just it's so he did have a
pretty good explanation for why caustics
are hard to render though so like with
he's this water bucket example
essentially
if imagine like a bucket filling up with
water is your render rendering
and
for a like a normal scene you take like
a hose and you're just filling it with
water if it's like a really complex
thing you got a lot of geometry a lot of
different complex textures maybe like
you're a little bit further away and
you're having to like kind of put your
thumb on the
the the hose to kind of get more of the
water to go further and into the bucket
rendering caustics is like standing 10
feet away from the bucket and putting
the nozzle into mist mode
and trying to fill the oh my god all
right now i'm gonna be rendering by
filling the bucket with water 10 feet
away
by shooting missed that direction and 11
years later you have your full bucket 11
years later
you're like have drained la of its water
supply
but your bucket is full yeah
and it has to do with like
for unbiased rendering to work there's
just there's just an infinite number of
rays to sample for the complexity of
light being refracted and so the
likelihood the chances of you finding
the correct ray
is so low it's like brute forcing
hacking a a password it's like imagine
you need to hack someone's account and
you're just guessing their password over
and over again that's like
that's kind of how traditionally
speaking
rendering caustics is
hey everyone uh as you can see i've come
to the fair and fertile lands of
minnesota to get some b-roll for my next
video project and uh well on the way
here i was told that that's not
necessary to do because uh courtesy of
today's sponsor's story blocks is a
place where you can have all of your
stock asset needs met because they have
a virtually unlimited library of high
quality 4k b-roll images audio assets
motion graphics after effects templates
and more and coming out to a farm to get
your own b-roll is actually not
necessary at all between the car rental
and the plane ticket and of course the
lodging while i'm up here um things are
kind of expensive probably more
expensive than a unlimited all-access
subscription to storyblocks which allows
you to download as much as you want
whenever you want and use it in anything
royalty free didn't think of that uh on
my way up here that not only would i
have to visit a farm uh to get some
b-roll for my video but also i'd have to
visit the arctic tundra and a couple
other places in europe if i had an
unlimited all-access plan on story
blocks i wouldn't have to do any of this
so um
yeah
so anyways if you are interested in
getting story blocks for yourself click
the link in the description below or
head on over to storyblocks.com
quartercast see what they got on there
for yourself and you don't have to
travel out to some place like this and
uh
just to get some shots of chickens
yeah anyways let's get back to the
podcast wow just keep guessing the
password until you eventually hit it now
how photon tracing the new render kernel
is different
ah
i don't know how to articulate it again
it's like it's just a thousand times
faster while still being unbiased it's
like encouraged but he jules said that
like it's they're still not caching
anything
uh they're still not doing anything that
is technically biased like with a bias
render engine say like mental ray you
can turn off global illumination you
could turn off soft shadows or shadows
period you can turn off like all these
different things but in an unbiased
render situation
it's all just physically simulated as if
it's real and you can't just turn off
global illumination or stuff like that
interesting right now at a point where
you can take that further and you can
disable certain things to not show up
but those are like hacks on top of the
unbiased rendering so get it to be
good in a workflow environment so fake
cosmetics fake caustics those are biased
results no is that how they're doing
okay so fake
fake caustics are essentially just
using a gobo
and a gobo is essentially just a pattern
that blocks light
so like a hand puppet shadow hand shadow
puppet
is a gobo yeah or like taking uh some
some plants like some ferns and putting
it in front of the light and that you
get that dappled lighting
a on someone yeah that is a gobo and a
caustic is essentially or a fake caustic
is essentially the same thing
you just you substitute out the the
texture image of a fern and you put in
caustics but it's doing that through an
object so like and so that is the way
it's doing that is as if it's any other
light source imagine like having an
a super big led panel but
you have a black and white image of a
caustic on that panel light is only
going to come from the the patterns of
light
or or light's only going to show up from
where it's not being blocked by the
this is a bad description
it's so hard to describe it
it's like the
the difference there between the real
and the fake one because you can get
pretty like if it's just the bottom of a
pool you can get a pretty consistent or
uh interesting result from that um but
like the actual light going through
the ripples in the pool is light being
bent yes so like the the fringes of that
light will have different colors because
it's like bending the spectrum of light
and stuff like that and that's if you
just use a gobo it's just a cut out it's
just like a shape you know but the
advantage is that by doing it fake like
that it's very cheap to render so it's
very quick to render and so uh
the basically this video kind of starts
out with me pointing out this shot from
prehistoric planet which all the vfx in
that show are pretty excellent so yeah i
gotta say it's so good one guy reached
out to me who worked on the shot that i
had shared on twitter oh dude he was
like oh we spent two years on that be
nice about the ice episode
and i think it's like
nice things to say it's amazing yeah
dude no spoilers i'm about to get
through the ice oh it's good nice
spoiler alert um yes i was like they all
died
so then i asked some follow-up questions
i was like did you do this with like
fake gobos like how did you do the the
stuff and he was like oh hit me up on
discord i was like well that's the end
of that conversation
i'm not gonna hit him up on discord oh
what's up i have a thing oh about
discord yeah i don't yeah it's it's my
work thing i don't want it to be my
social media thing so it's it's
it's a bit of a thing it it yeah that's
fair fair enough i don't want to go into
it it's yeah that's fair same reason why
i have like a thousand
friend requests on facebook
what's when is the last time you went on
facebook i have given up i stopped using
facebook for about two years you're back
i'm back oh he's better because i needed
to join a couple one wheel related
facebook forums okay i'm glad you said
one wheel
it's the only reason why i'm back i'm
i don't wanna i don't wanna talk about
it too much publicly lit yet but it has
to do with
one wheels that are not made by anyway
um
i don't want to go into that just yet
it's it's it's complicated politically
um the main point is you're back on
facebook though facebook is it
complicated politically yeah yeah
i i i i don't check it i don't yeah well
that's the problem so now i've actually
fallen behind following up on this one
wheel project because i don't have
notifications on facebook turned on and
so it's just kind of out of sight out of
mind it's just like
my object permanence is just like it's
not there it doesn't exist it's
fantastic that was why i stopped using
facebook i turned off notifications and
it stopped existing and before i knew it
enough time had gone by my phone auto
uninstalled facebook nice that's a cool
feature apple's like you don't need to
be using this like oh you haven't got
this in 90 days uh we're going to
offload that storage
for other things that's good isn't it
crazy that
facebook is just i mean i still tons and
tons of people use it but i would say
it's kind of fallen
out of kind of mainstream use absolutely
isn't that crazy i mean it's like well
like well it's like like myspace and now
like it's just it's happened and i think
it's the really interesting thing about
all these like um
you know proceedings about the power of
these social media platforms is like hey
guys just wait five years it's gonna be
there's gonna be a whole new company
yeah yeah you know i guess the weird
thing is that instagram is also facebook
like it's or i guess it's all meta now
yeah but but you ha like instagram like
who knows maybe in five years the kids
will be using
tick tock beam or whatever the next
beam wow
first download beam at the ios store
that might i think that's a real one
let me know what uh what time traveling
device you used for that too
yeah i mean it was dead it went out of
business years ago it's so weird because
it is like
like
is tick-tock the most popular social
media platform now
i don't know about the most like how do
you measure most popular most number of
new users engagements
total users yeah engagement like i'm not
exactly sure yeah tick-tock has blown up
obviously um
i actually kind of like tick tock quite
a bit
it's very addicting it's it's extremely
addicting and and
i have found that the content on tick
tock actually is pretty wholesome
typically like i don't know tick tock
has this reputation based on your like
algorithm though so that just means
you're a nice wholesome person but like
i mean sure but i keep seeing so many
different posts of like it's just some
random person talking about a story or
talking about a thing and and they're
just doing all of the video editing
inside of tick tock and they're it
it has lowered the uh
barrier to entry more democratic yeah
yeah it's it's so easy to create content
now and just put it out there that we're
seeing a huge number of people just
starting to do that yeah you know it
started with youtube i mean you can now
upload your own thing but like you still
had to do everything yourself offline
and then like deliver a file that's all
it was was a video style sharing yeah
it's like what is going to be the next
youtube will there ever be another
youtube channel yeah that's when they
talk like youtube's feels like it's
still like ever present yeah i think it
has to be like tick-tock is a different
medium entirely and like nothing can
ever replace youtube's place in the
market as
like long-form i mean that's the thing
that was like you just said nothing and
it's like i'm sure people said that
about myspace i'm sure people said that
about it but i think like like facebook
did something different than myspace and
it just kind of
consumed i guess that realm of people's
attention and like tick tock still like
takes attention away from youtube for
young people yeah um i don't i trust
take talk i don't either
it's yeah
there are positive sides of it there's
great content on there like any platform
but there's something very nefarious
about the
uh interface it is as close to a slot
machine as i've ever seen
yeah any app
it's like
there's no there's no like sub feed
really there is
but they they drop you right in on like
like it's like if you open youtube well
there's the recommended there's not like
a chronological
sub feed but yeah it's a sub feed but
they'll throw stuff that was like two
months ago they're like oh you haven't
seen this yet we think you'll like it
because it's it's entirely algorithmic i
just i wonder i mean this is a total
floating theory that i have with no
evidence to back it up but i feel like
everyone that i know has had one video
that popped off that got them to like
really want to keep making stuff mm-hmm
a little taste of it i think there's now
keep going there's a degree of that yeah
but at the same time your video has to
be good your video still has to like
land on other people's pages and they
have to pay attention enough to get go
through it
and that tells tik tok like oh people
are interested in this well it's
good or it has to be attention grabbing
that's i mean okay yeah you're right
which is those are not mutually slightly
different things and i think it's again
like it's hijacking our
like
you know when you're scrolling through
reddit or something there's just this
thing of like oh i'm getting new
information constantly but it's like
you're reading right but tiktok it's
like just shooting it straight into your
brain every 12 seconds or whatever the
you know next thing you know three hours
have gone by and you haven't moved an
inch and like i am waiting in my life
yeah that's such a scary download i
already feel like i do that with reddit
but i can justify it by being like well
i'm sort of learning some stuff yeah
well to be fair like i've had to go to a
point where i was like okay i have to
like only subscribe to subreddits that i
actually will be like
yeah learning from or it's like you know
reading the newspaper so yeah for me
it's i'm like my reddit is like hockey
and vfx yeah
it's like so lame but it's like i can't
be like looking at memes or like r funny
because then i'll just be doing that for
four hours yeah i'm not gonna lie for a
moment there i thought you just
mispronounced hawkeye
hawkeye oh my gosh she's a huge hawkeye
fan because she worked on hawkeye yeah
and so for for a moment just for a split
second i was like oh you follow hawkeye
and vfx
like that's a weird way to pronounce
hawkeye my favorite superhero he
actually he actually has jeremy renner's
app dude
that's still wild that that exists
that's what's going to take over tick
tock jeremy right around yeah
everybody's going to be on jeremy
renner's app dude i did not know he had
that yeah it was like a whole thing
he seems like he seems like a really
cool guy like i heard about him yeah
shepard's podcast he seems really cool
but it seems like his marketing people
were like hey man you need an app for
all like the middle-aged moms who like
all the fans of hockey
man there was definitely a period of
time there several years ago where i
would get a lot of emails from people
being like hey we want to build you an
app
oh really yeah what are they going to do
with it uh
it was like it was like a place where
you can put your videos up and have like
forums and and and like engage with your
community and like people could download
the app clint did it oh he had one he
doesn't use it anymore like i i never
ended up doing anything like i never
even pursued it i don't think i ever
even responded to one of those emails
but it's like i would get them and i
know other people would get them too
and i've got an idea that went away why
don't we scan you right
and then you can take a tour of ren and
you can just look around
there you go i think there's a jeremy
renner app i'm telling you are there
payment tears
i'm telling you if that wasn't the
jeremy runner app if you could take a
tour of jeremy renner that would be one
of the hottest features on that
man that's nuts yeah it's a hard to know
from you
i brought this thing in here today this
is the insta360
one rs
and this is their brand new flagship
model because it has their one inch
sensor on it dual one inch sensors and
it's really nice
the one so to be clear uh
this is like the new part here it's the
just the lens essentially their whole 1r
the 1rs it's a modular system and the
1rs that was launched earlier this year
is waterproof but this specific mod
is not waterproof
why would that matter
that would matter if you want to go
swimming with it in the ocean say this
morning
and uh and you tell we get our shot and
then you tell dean oh i'm just gonna run
in the water with my 360 camera just get
a shot real quick
and we so we have all this footage of
friend running around in the water with
his this 360 camera on this pole like
just diving in just baptizing him
he's just dunking it in the water and
then today he's like oh wait it's not
like all the files are corrupted oh wait
it's not waterproof
uh yeah no the camera's straight up dead
it's straight up dead like i see water
inside this little like screen thing
here
uh
yeah because like it's water resistant
and it has all of this waterproofing
stuff on it it was obviously my mistake
uh did you just take your nintendo
switch out in the water and you're just
like i do think like come on man it's an
action camera it should be waterproof
like
but it is you said one of the models are
yeah but not this one it's like look at
how it's almost worse though it's like
you can't just be like the earlier model
is waterproof and then a later release
isn't like yeah like that's like if
gopro the new gopro they're like it's
not waterproof because we're in surprise
surprise
yeah so i texted the guy who uh like
runs the marketing for insta360 a friend
of mine i like him a lot and
you know he's our contact with the
company and
yeah i uh
i told him that i killed it
and he's by getting it
submerged in water he's like
i didn't know it wasn't waterproof and
he says yeah uh it says that in the fine
print that no one reads
yes that's where it would be
and so but like two like i was like i
thought this was waterproof so i looked
it up because it was literally announced
today this is the first time this has
been announced and and so like i can now
publicly research this the information's
out there and yeah technically at the
bottom of the page it says it's ip
something it's it's water resistant but
do not submerge it and don't do any sort
of intense water activities like surfing
and that's essentially what i was doing
there's literally we have a shot of you
body surfing
[Laughter]
on day one of the release that's so
great yeah i'm bummed because this is
actually like a super sick camera i i
shot a bunch over the weekend one
wheeling up on the mountains with it and
the it's hard to describe how big this
the glass is on this it's a it's a leica
lens i was about to say zeiss definitely
not zeiss like it um it's like bigger
than my eye socket yeah
it's kind of freaky to think about
mm-hmm
yeah so yeah and this does brackets this
guy follow on instagram just posted his
like i guess now that you're allowed to
post them and it was super cool he did
like a mountain biking video in nelson
bc
i think his instagram name is like john
cemo but it's so crazy he had like
the bike rider like holding it on like a
pole on his handlebars so you're like
getting this crazy like biking foot yeah
that's awesome oh cool dude like yeah
what what is the the difference between
this and the last model um it's the same
as the last model so the only thing
that's actually new is not waterproof
the glass okay this sensor here is the
new thing so it's a much bigger sensor
so it's much better in low light
less noisy footage when it's dark
interesting
and you know just like anytime you get
bigger glass you're going to get better
optics or sorry the the image quality
will be better typically the bigger your
glass is okay and so that's that's kind
of the idea around this mod now the rest
of this stuff uh this module was
announced at the beginning of the year
this is the one rs and it's just like
the brain and then you can attach little
battery modules to it and that's what
this little thing is here behind it and
it's all it's in this specific case that
attaches to the lens so this only works
with this casing configuration yeah it's
super modular
and i love the modularity of it they
have versions that have like little
regular action cam lenses like a gopro
lens uh they have a big gopro lens they
have regular 360 lenses and uh we did a
video a couple years ago where they have
a split lens that you can attach to it
with like a little ribbon cable and i
attached those to a drone on the top and
bottom
which basically makes it so that the
drone was invisible oh
cool so i can fly the drone around and
get any shot i want because there's
nothing in the way it's just a floating
eye yeah yeah and i i thought that was a
super compelling idea and
made a whole video where i like
literally 3d printed and designed my own
like mounting stuff for it and i
scratched multiple lenses because i kept
hitting the ground
lens is like the most exposed thing and
it has to be the most outer thing for
anything inside of it to be invisible so
yeah yeah that was a weird thing they
just also announced a new version of
their own official
god mode type camera thing they call it
the
something
like that wow oh dude is that the
creative name
the sphere that's what it is it's the
insta360 sphere
and it works with the
dji mavic
air ii
my the reason i straight away from the
reason i strayed away from insta360 was
because i wasn't having any luck getting
separate bracketed photographs in my
hdris yeah which you know everything
would be compressed into a single jpeg
that was like it would you know the
range was in there but it was 8-bit so
it's like i'm not getting the full depth
of the beauty
this has been a point of contention
between me and insta362 because like
they promised me that this ability would
be a thing
several years ago and i talked about it
in a video and it still hasn't quite
become a feature technically it is there
you have to like do some specific things
you have to like save it out save out
the dng raw files in the brackets and it
will actually save out the multiple
different images
in a raw setting so you can just open up
your folder drag and drop those into
photoshop and create your hdr file out
of it okay and it just feels like
something that should just be a like
well that's the thing their their market
is like the action camera market the
best market they're not really tailoring
their stuff towards vfx artists but i
have a feeling if they did they would
suddenly have a whole market of people
being like oh yeah i need this for my
renters yeah yeah right now it's not
quite at that easy enough to use stage
yet right and
yeah so it's like that's why i went with
the theta z that's what i have
and it's like you can basically set up
your exposure settings for every single
bracket and then it'll
take them like inside of one minute so
when i was on set i just pop it i just
clear set for just a literally a minute
and get my my full range and then be
able to make the hdris however i wanted
so to be clear this does that yeah it
doesn't but you have access to
like because i guess
i think i can make nine brackets and
i'll save nine different images at nine
different exposures yeah uh going from
super dark to super brights
and all you do is you press one button
and it'll start taking those photos and
it'll do it pretty quickly like yeah in
a couple seconds i'm wondering if the
model i had was the one before that was
a function
it still gave me like a nice range in
the hdr it took multiple exposures but
it put them all together and i never
found a way to make it maybe just wasn't
intuitive so you were so using an hdr a
full like 32-bit uh exr file or
something or well how was it from theta
z yeah uh no i just get uh traditional
images i can't remember what what the
file extension was for those but i would
then run them into photoshop okay that's
okay hdr but with this
i never found a way to get the bracketed
photographs and that might have been the
version that i had but i'd always only
get a jpeg
that was the full range put together
with like the lows and the highs kind of
pushed towards each other that's the
problem with the term hdr it's it's
become one of those ubiquitous terms
that applies to a lot of different
things so it's hard because hdr just
means high dynamic range and so if you
have an image with hdr it just means
you're able to see the details in the
shadows and the details and the
highlights so it's true
you know a greater dynamic range and
there's ways to sort of like take
multiple exposures and merge that into
one image that you can share online and
whatnot um
but the 8-bit banding was just
yeah i mean yeah if it's an 8-bit or if
it's a jpeg at all you're not going to
be able to use that for vfx i mean
you'll be able to use it as like a
reflection type thing but when we talk
in hdri it's hdr image
and that's the idea of like an actual
high bit depth like you can turn down
the exposure on a picture like you do
the exposure on a camera yeah you know
you can you can if you're if you point
your your camera
at a light bulb it's just going to be a
big white spot but if you specifically
start cranking the shutter speed to the
point that like it starts getting darker
and darker you can actually see the
outline of like the curly q's of a light
bulb it's very fun
pretty cool yeah imagine doing that on
an image that has already been taken
that's the that's the whole idea of an
hdri it has all of the light information
baked in and uh that is very very nice
when it comes to 3d rendering because
now you can just plop that in the scene
and now you're getting all kinds of
light directionality light intensity
light color all just baked into a single
image and like just it works really well
really really well i saw peter uh one
time did where he projected the hdri on
to geometry yeah so you like rebuilt the
environment yeah projection mapping hdri
it was very cool yeah and so then you
actually have your 3d geometry with
a miss of textures and also just and but
that texture
has the correct light intensity baked in
so anything that's not supposed to be
bright isn't going to be emitting that
much light and you can take that further
if you're doing like i know ian hubert's
method to like take a photo scan in a
certain spot and then take an hdri in
that same spot and
basically invert that and light the the
photo scan
with that and it removes all the shadows
i really gotta ask him about it i'm not
exactly sure how it works
in principle you know like i think i get
it like you're multiplying the inverse
so it's lifting the dark values and
keeping
it's not multiplying against the light
values so you're getting a lift just in
the dark but i'd love to pick his brain
on that yeah if i ever get to meet him
every time i talk with michael he's i'm
telling him like we gotta get this like
bracketed exposure thing working he's
like
it's there it should work i'm like okay
show me and he'll show me i'm like well
goddamn yep there it is
he can do it he's not wrong yeah uh it's
just hidden just enough that i can never
remember how to return it on or do it
again
and it is you still have to take the sd
card out of the camera plug it in go to
the folder and take the stuff out and so
i was like
that's enough though if you can make it
easier to do
and
but what would be nicer is if you can
automatically turn that into a a dot exr
dot hdr file that would be already
merged together and all i have to do is
just take that one file and i can drag
and drop because then what i really want
to do is i want to make an hdri sequence
going down a road
and then you can have like say a chrome
dragon or something just static with the
hdri playing around it but it'll look
like it's flying down a road yeah
but that's too impractical to do right
now because you have to take a whole
bunch of images and you have to process
it all out for one frame and now do that
30 times a second that or you just deal
with the eight bit video
yeah yeah i mean that would be yeah you
could do it i've done that yeah i've
done that where you just take a 360
video you put it in in your your hdri
environment you don't get the lighting
information but you get the reflection
yeah it's kind of like
you know caustics for real versus a gobo
classics for real versus gobos uh fake
caustic gobos work way better than that
yeah but just in terms of like
the whole idea of vfx is like you know
what's
what's good enough like
you know if you can't tell doesn't
matter kind of a thing exactly oh it's
all a lie anyway yeah exactly all alive
so that's kind of the final point we
make in this caustics video is that like
i go through all of this effort in this
journey to try to get
real caustics real all of this stuff and
at the end i'm like wow it looks just
the same as the gobo
what's the point
and and then kind of conclude with the
thought that like all visual effects are
faking it to such a high degree that
like you know you can't compare anything
to reality yeah as long as you can get
away with the lie yeah as long as it
looks real and works like usually
something
we're at a point now where like the
small little like
little things that make stuff a little
bit more realistic matters
to make it look better but at the end of
the day
like we were talking about um aces cg
right accg versus asus cc yeah you know
and then it's like the discovery seems
to be so minimal it was like a number it
was like a 480 number and like 2 000 or
a c in there or something but yeah i
like remember uh and and again i can't
even speak to the specifics of why i
said this but apparently aces cg
doesn't handle color as correctly as
normal aces yeah
uh
yeah i don't know i don't know too much
about that i was like okay then we
probably shouldn't go that route we
should probably use the more correct
version and then i was like
it all looks good yeah like once you're
in the asus
workspace anyway it's so beautiful
and it's like how much can you get away
with in that department yeah it it's
such a thing because like with
you know vfx there's such an idea of
like oh it has to be perfect but
often something that will be perfect and
like the correct way won't actually look
as good and won't be like what the human
eye is used to seeing especially on
screen because you're used to like
you know there's like real versus
cinematic and often someone viewing that
is going to be like well i like the
cinematic one better and it's like you
know it it kind of boils down so it's
like does it look good yeah and that's
all that matters well
that's the art in it right yeah i've
seen some sunsets yeah i've seen some
sunsets that look so fake
if i did that as my work i wouldn't be
done yet i'd be like this is this
doesn't make any sense how is it
possible another great example is muzzle
flashes like real muzzle flashes
sometimes you can't even see them like
sometimes they're just not there your
camera doesn't like or just tiny little
thing and like
but if you saw that on screen you'd be
like oh that's kind of lame yeah i mean
i think probably the biggest example of
that is
uh outer space yeah photos taken in
space they never look real they always
look so harsh and contrasty and like not
good you're like this because it doesn't
look real and so but then every movie or
tv show space looks awesome yeah and
it's very unrealistic
but it feels real and that's the point
it's like as long as like whoever's
watching it believes what they're
watching is real that's the only thing
that matters so like this is something
nico and i have talked about on
on vfx stars react or at some point in
the past i don't know man
making videos for so long now uh
hollywood
reality sorry there's there's like
realistic and hollywood realistic that's
that's similar to the same sort of thing
that you were talking about there is
that like
you know explosions
are never how they are depicted in in
movies yeah and yet we kind of believe
that that's how explosions work because
that's what we've seen in movies and so
when we actually see how explosions work
for real
we don't buy it yeah it's underwhelming
well dean you were talking about the
level of blood in a human body yeah well
that was the day that was remember seth
rogan was talking about um
in it was the opening of preacher he was
talking about but the same thing if
anybody's watching the boys is like the
amount of blood that are in people
is insane and it's also
directly correlated with like how hard
somebody's getting killed
it's like if you're getting killed super
hard
you got way more blood suddenly i shot
him super hard yeah right like you get
punched by like a by like homelander you
explode into a bunch of pieces but if
someone stabs you it's like yeah like
there's a chemical thing that's going on
that generates more blood yeah from the
impact
yeah no i'm remembering what he said now
because it was like on preacher on that
opening scene this dude explodes and
sprays the entire crowd
in this chapel with blood and they kept
having to bring in more and more blood
and at a point they're like this is more
blood than the human body has and his
response was like who cares we need more
blood it's not it's not impactful enough
we need more blood in the shot it
doesn't matter the technicalities of all
this stuff and yeah yeah i think there's
something interesting there of like
as the tools get more democratic for vfx
and it's like easier and easier to make
things look
physically based realistic
it just brings more and more into focus
how important the
artistic interpretive element is because
like you're saying with the conclusion
of this video is kind of like you will
never replicate reality it's literally
impossible because a computer can't make
an infinite like
reality is just it is you know yeah and
yeah like
the
that's like the artistic side of it the
hand crafted side of it is almost
becoming more
more relevant to people like like a lot
of movies that are
taking a more
like incorporating more practical
effects i think people respond to that
not because it's like
it looks better in some vague kind of
way but because it has the touch of like
a human being rather than a computer you
know
dean this might be super relevant to you
but
the star wars sequel trilogy are there
specific shots from the movies that
stand out to you in those like that's
just what popped in my head as beautiful
or as like janky as beautiful as like
just like for me i'm thinking i think
it's in
uh force awakens they do like the
apocalypse now tie fighter shot
you know where it's like that oh with
the sun it doesn't make any sense
because it's like afternoon sun in that
shot yeah but it looks so sick so who
cares that's a todd kaziri shot right
there right it's so or he competed so
sick and then there's like the um
uh last jedi the freaking hyperspace
like one oh yeah and that's totally
interpretive that's like a shot from an
anime film and yeah everyone
loves it yeah everybody gets them from
classy i mean like we thought you will
about the new uh star wars sequels i
thought they were beautiful at the very
least yeah totally but that's the thing
it's like those shots they don't really
make sense but they look
amazing yeah so it's the meaning it's
like what does it mean to the story and
like
you know not to bring up freaking rrr
again this amazing indian film that
we're all raving about
but
that movie has
every moment essentially is just
completely interpretive it's like so
distant from reality but
like there's a shot where they're like
light that man up you know and they they
pan over the lights like as if they're
going to pan them on him like from your
perspective and then suddenly he's being
backlit
these sweet volumes behind him it's just
like total hero po and you're like
awesome yeah no but it's this yeah so
the
the image is more important from an
artistic perspective always than it is
from like a well did it you know is it
real yeah yeah but at the same time it's
like
using the tools to make it as real as
possible
or rather it just assists
whoever's creating the thing to be what
they want it to be yeah you know
especially if what they're trying to
make is supposed to be
realistic yeah like uh
everything in avatar too they're
essentially doing it all as physically
accurate as possible it's working it
looks so good yeah it's like so so like
a big question of mine in fact this is
actually still a bit of a question mark
in this video we're doing uh probably
not by the time you guys are saying this
because it's out
hopefully um
is whether or not they are physically
simulating those caustics in avatar too
because you can see caustics a few
different moments in the trailer and
there's one in particular that blew my
mind from the avatar 2 trailer where uh
i don't know who it is they're holding
on to a whale as the camera's like kind
of flipping upside down and he's like
soaring along underneath the surface of
the water but you see all of the
caustics on the whale and on him but
you're also seeing the surface of the
water in the same shot and so
that is something that you can fake
by basically having like a gobo fake
caustics being projected in and and the
the actual sort of water surface itself
isn't emitting those
caustics but
i wouldn't put it past weta to actually
simulate that for real and just like oh
yeah we just have a unified system we
don't ever have to like tweak anything
to make it work we never have to hack
anything together which is what we're
always doing as effects artists it's
like oh this is
almost there you know what i'm gonna
like make it work here make it work
there cobble it together
now it looks amazing yeah all the
stitches on the back of it are hidden
from the camera exactly monstrosity so i
think their their entire goal and
purpose is to like
try to make a unified system that
requires less of that so that they can
have more or quicker turnaround times on
iterations and stuff like that and
well you know just presuming rendering's
not a problem for them at the same time
caustics how long how long has it been
since avatar one like
2009 13 years 13 years yeah it takes 11
years to render caustic
but yeah so like we uh we have a contact
at weta and we we asked uh we asked them
two questions what their rendering
engine is which you actually already
know he said it was
[Music]
manuka
i have no idea how well that renders
caustics but secondly i was just like
did they fake the caustics or did they
simulate them for real and we have not
heard back yet and so very likely in
this video it'll just have to be
speculation to this day like that if i
could just turn invisible one of the
first things i do is just go eavesdrop
on all like the big post houses just to
see their internal
structures and what they have access to
and the tools they have built like i bet
there's so much amazing stuff that just
on our and we just can't even fathom
what's possible so yeah caustics-wise
the fact that we have you know and
obtain that new kernel it just must mean
that
in in those places those top-secret
environments they must have just
fantastic solutions to these problems
well perhaps but i don't think caustics
is the thing anyone else has actually
solved
i'm pretty sure otoy is the only company
that has solved like uh spectrally
correct caustics james cameron what say
you
just personally invented the way to do
it
it wasn't what they they just like
they're just using his name yeah
i mean just the idea of having a
like farm of
computers like we're here like we have a
bunch of 30 90s in the studio like we
can get out renders much faster than i
could at home on my like janky computer
but like there some of the stuff we kick
out you could kick out in like seconds
at one of these places just like shoot
it out to all the to the farm we could
do that here oh yeah we could and and we
could get that all set up uh
yeah it would be like could be 10
computers versus like hundreds you know
well yeah because they have it on
full-on like server racks where it's
like a computer is literally just like a
little wafer in a in a tray yeah we
literally used baking racks at one of
our studios really yeah like you know
the classic like slide of like you know
baking sheet in
those at one point so i think honestly
the future of rendering
uh not to like
put too much emphasis on cryptocurrency
or anything but otoy has this thing
called render token and if you know how
crypto works and how it's like a
distributed network of
a bunch of different computers and gpus
all just kind of like working on a
problem
otoy was like well instead of just like
trying to figure out whether or not
someone actually made a purchase what if
they're rendering an engine sorry
rendering what if that computer is just
rendering an image and so when you
actually submit something to the render
network uh you you pay for it using the
render tokens it's like it's still a
kind of a crypto thing
but your image then gets uploaded
encrypted and distributed to a million
different gpus
and
and then you you get your image back you
just download it there's no like sort of
render form it goes to it's all just
distributed interesting and and it's
very fast they're saying it's actually
significantly faster than going to like
a render farm and clint uh did a a
render recently that he said would have
taken him
a hundred hours
to render
uh but he was able to get it back in
like minutes
that's and we're using this method yeah
yeah it was either minutes or maybe
hours or in a day i forget but it was
like enough that
uh over the weekend i was like man i
gotta finally get into this i've been
i've been known about this this thing
for literally three years now have you
ever done an online render farm i never
have anything no it is the most exciting
thing in the world you package up your
scene you send it off and you're
literally watching in real time as it's
getting completed and if you're like me
i only go to it when i really need it so
that means i've tested without it and
it's incomparable but the one that i
used i can't even remember what it was
now it's been a couple years that keeps
a ticker of how much it costs too so as
a freelancer i was out of pocket for me
out of like the sun that i was charging
and just watching the money leave my
wallet was the counter side to this
speed that was just blazing
yeah it's a very cool experience though
that's definitely always going to be the
sort of like flip side of that and i
don't really know what the the cost
comparisons are off the top my head
right now but
i mean you know it's like can you
imagine being like you know what i want
to do a render in a few weeks that's
going to be pretty nuts so i'm just
going to let my render my computer you
know just render for someone else for
the next couple weeks make enough sort
of render tokens that you can then spend
on your next render i didn't even
register yeah you can give yours up to
generate tokens because everyone who
puts their computer up on the network
is earning that sort of like that same
thing that you do if you're if you're
mining freaking like ethereum or big
dude all those crypto people who sold
their gpus after the crypto crash are
like trying to buy them back up now
it's kind of like communism though
you know what i mean we're all just
helping each other
it's not your render it's ours it's our
render
yeah that's cool that's a really great
idea i i might i might start doing that
that's it i've literally been wanting to
get into it for a long time and if oh so
it's already out there oh yeah no it's
been around for a little while but it's
it's still kind of convoluted not only
do you have to be good at understanding
how to package up your render
uh
within all of the stuff that you would
need for otoy and you know like an orbix
file and all of like this stuff and
that's already a learning curve on its
own you also kind of have to understand
how crypto works and how you you have to
get like the wallets and like all the
and get it uploaded and it's a bit of a
thing i think clint might actually make
a tutorial for it because he had to like
bang his head against the wall a lot and
needed a lot of help to get just his one
thing going and now he knows it and him
and i were supposed to kind of like chat
about this today but i just i did not
have time um and
he was he was texting me and he was like
i think i might just go ahead and make a
tutorial like please do that'd be super
fun i know it's super niche clamp but
that would be very awesome
thank you
yeah that's very cool um so before we
wrap this up i want to point out this
little toy here in case you
noticed it in my hand it's a it's
essentially two little rolling pins uh
it's two cylinders of metal with uh what
do you call a ball bearings at the end
like little rolling bearings so it's
like a little bit of a fidget toy it's
kind of like a fidget spinner
and it just rolls around in your hand
you can kind of just like do this with
it
it's a nice little stress reliever and
just kind of have something to do with
my hands i've never really been into
fidget toys or anything but mark
the podcast i was on with mark a few
weeks back he had a little pink one and
he was he was playing around with it i
thought it was like a vape or something
like that at first i was like what are
you playing with this oh whatever um
that's mark the player yeah markiplier
yeah our internet last name applies yeah
mark
that's playa markiplier
what's it called what is this this is
called an ono oh n o it's like 35 bucks
on amazon this is the stainless steel
version that's like 60 bucks
but it's a lot heavier it has like that
heft it's i mean like
oh it's hefty yeah oh my gosh it's very
satisfying it's a true heifer look at
that i find myself just like playing
with it absent-mindedly
it's really nice i love it yeah that's
actually really nice i think it was like
literally after that podcast is like hey
check this out and i was like i'm
getting one right now
and i literally like i opened my phone
and bought one right then and there
that's awesome i honestly might do the
same thing now that i've used yours this
is heavier than uh mark last name of
player
yeah yeah it's like three times heavier
wow i like it let me hit that okay the
only problem is that like
uh here okay i'll
i'll pretend i'll mime it uh i was
hanging out with jan the other night uh
and we were sitting at a table getting
dinner and i had it in my hand and i was
just but under the table in between my
legs i was just like
and i realized what i was doing i was
like okay now i have to make a point to
always have it off to my side when i'm
playing with it or something
that would be the worst if you're doing
that and then you make eye contact with
someone realize and then instinctively
say i'm not doing what you think i'm
doing and then you just look very guilty
that was exactly what happened oh
unfortunately
well
i was like oh i'm
just non-verbally i was like and i'm
gonna put it on the table and i saw him
like look down on it and we can like
neither of us like acknowledged it
dude now we gotta do a podcast we're all
holding it just
staring at each other while we do it all
of us are gonna have the same callous on
our palm from just doing it all day long
because it's like this is like i feel
the ultimate spiritual successor to the
fidget spinner mm-hmm because i think
spiders kind of did it for me you know
it was like you'd spin it you're like
yeah but it still required active input
you had to like
spin it or like some weird little thing
with your hand there yeah this is like
you could just
all day yeah it's just like you just sit
in your hand
as opposed to like say a stress ball
it's not really for stress it's for it's
somewhere between stress and fidgeting
it's very cool oh no yeah
i've never really been a fidgeter i've
never really
fidgeted much i don't like tap my shoe
or play well
but your brain fidgets
and we need to give it something to
focus on yeah so this is proven to be
pretty helpful so do we want to shout
out the fans if they have any ideas uh
similar to the spice cast oh yeah i'm
out there
it was actually jonah and i came up with
that one because we
hate yourself
but the spice house was very fun to be a
part of and very painful especially the
next day dude i mean
freaking we did the hot ones challenge
for christian's birthday party like few
years back and that was uh i was like
cool never again yeah unless it's
actually on the hot ones show that's the
only other time i'll i'll do it dude
yeah ice bucket podcast yeah everybody's
in an ice bath you see how long oh my
gosh yeah i don't even think i could get
in ice bath elk me dmt
to kick out tonight i'm probably going
to be here late uh
hopefully no all-nighters this week like
yeah but sweet i'm really excited to see
fantastic video yeah i'm excited to
learn something me too
oh rather i'm excited
when you commit to the response too
quick yeah
pretty much thanks for watching everyone
thanks for listening for those of you
not watching and we will listen to you
in the next one
that's an idea have a nice day